foreign
odd story that I don't want to focus on
led me to something that I think we
ought to talk a little bit about
um the odd story is somebody erroneously
accused me of plagiarism uh on the
internet they tried to coin a hashtag
and then it turned out that I had in
fact said the thing that they claimed I
had copied from them before they ever
said it so not only did I not get it
from them but the order was reversed
it was an unwitting plagiarist claiming
that you would plagiarize them I think
it was a canonical the phrase was uh I
had said that the Omicron virus had
appeared to be Frozen in Time
then the person uh concluded that I must
have gotten that from them they had
another piece of evidence which also
doesn't establish this but it turned out
I had said it online before they had
before the point at which they pointed
out but it doesn't really matter that's
it's secondary to the the important
consideration here
person in question
I don't have any reason to believe that
they are
a white nationalist or anything like
this but they do seem to have some
followers of this nature which I
discovered because in interacting with
their claim that I had engaged in
plagiarism these people showed up and my
being Jewish was important to them oh
good so anyway it was fun that was
disturbing yes but then the really
disturbing thing happened something
about my having interacted with those
people online kicked me over into Nazi
Twitter
something that I did not know existed
some algorithm starts showing you Nazi
tweets yeah and I ain't talking about
white nationalist stuff I'm not talking
about race realism right those things
are bad enough I'm talking about actual
Nazi Twitter I'm talking about
awning videos of the fuhrer making nice
with children that have been put
together with soaring wistful music
really didn't know it was on there
shocked to discover it yeah so anyway on
the one hand the my point would be oh
Nazi Twitter exists real Nazi Twitter
real Holocaust denying
your loving Twitter is a real thing but
the more important thing I thought even
beyond that shocking discovery
was that it exists and the way Twitter
functions
I was completely unaware of it yeah was
a surprise they were white nationalists
but I was surprised to see the depth of
this and so I do think it raises
there are several things that have
worked this way right so Elon did a
bunch of work to get rid of
um pedophile Twitter I don't exactly
know where that stands because pedophile
Twitter isn't something I was aware of
until that uh
if you're erupted a fewer is a bad term
in this discussion but it's spelled
differently oh good I'm rarely thankful
for such things but in this case I am I
think really it's pronounced you know
yeah differently as well so furore
versus furor yeah yeah but anyway okay I
wasn't really very different word
entirely wow yeah yes
um but okay so there there the point is
there are aspects of Twitter that would
cause a normal person to absolutely
shudder in horror and these things it's
as if you know you are riding on the bus
with
um you know murderous Thugs who you
don't know are there and they're you
know making eye contact maybe they're
smiling at you as they're you know
plotting whatever it is they're plotting
and I'm not making an argument here for
what should be true
I don't know what should be true but I
am making an argument that it is vitally
important that to the extent that
um these uh communities
arise and live in our midst it's kind of
important that we know that they're
there
[Music]